après celle du 15 décembre nouvelle
désillusion pour les acteurs du monde
culturel qui espère ouvrir le 20 janvier
prochain en raison des données
sanitaires actuelles musées cinémas ou
encore théâtre vont devoir rester fermé
pour l'instant c'est ce qu'a annoncé le
porte-parole du gouvernement le 1er
janvier on a prévu tout à partir du 20
janvier à une série de dates parce qu'on
nous a quand même parlé du 20 janvier
c'était la date la plus lointaine
soi-disant mais j'ai peur que
malheureusement ce soit une date de
revoyure une réouverture tant espéré
qu'ils n'arrivent pas et des dates sans
arrêt repoussé qui ne permettent pas aux
acteurs locaux de se projeter et les
attentes des déclarations claires de la
part du gouvernement
moi je préférerais qu'on me disais que
tu étais pas gelé jusqu'au 1er mars
vous pouvez pas jouer jusqu'au 1er avril
parce qu'on s'organiserait autrement
alors que là en réalité on ne peut pas
s'organiser cédé 10 jours en huit jours
qu'on prévient les spectateurs donc tous
les dix jours ont leurs écrits bon bah
désolé mais là on va pas pouvoir jouer
donc c'est une espèce de mauvaise
organisation qui tient pas debout
plutôt que de faire du stop and go en
permanence moi mon point de vue c'est
que je préfère qu'on soit fermé on
arrête tout on en finit avec l'épidémie
et on démarre comme avant les acteurs du
monde culturel comprennent que
l'épidémie ne permet pas d'avoir une
date fixe de reprise
ils se tiennent prêts à rouvrir leurs
portes et attendent le feu vert du
gouvernement
vous nous avez fait confiance au mois de
mai lorsque nous avons ouvert
faites nous confiance nous avons pris
les mesures nécessaires pour permettre
de travailler dans de bonnes conditions
nous sommes vraiment utile nous
souhaitons vivement pouvoir accompagner
nos concitoyens et obtenir d'eux vous
rapidement une ouverture les
établissements culturels n'ont pas
rouvert leurs portes depuis octobre
dernier